hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the devil haunts me a
survival type game kind of like I mean I
guess I can't even say what it's kind of
like it is a game where you're lost
alone in the woods and you need to
survive as long as you possibly can to
try to unravel the mystery that lies
inside the forest does that make sense
it might and then again it might not but
I'm gonna go for it why don't anyone
play with the audio off a bunch of big
bubble-blowing babies whoo hi and this
is you by the way Oh oh my god I'm cute
ZD use item C to zoom out to zoom okay
ax plus tree equals log shotgun plus
something equals red glowing rock a cup
of black coffee plus dice equal water
bucket water bucket plus well equals
water I don't know what any of that
means man plus lightning equals bed okay
that doesn't make the most of oh [ __ ] oh
my god oh my god oh I got an axe okay I
can only take one at a time woah look at
me go yeah yeah yeah okay oh my god it's
like to rock this is this is funky oh
this is funkalicious this is funky fresh
Hey okay bye dear okay
all right well then whoa what's that
green thing what is it why is everything
so black and white why is everything so
scary in the forest I don't like this at
all
okay what what is that what is that
toilet paper what is that it's a hand
what where's their head why their heads
okay never mind then all right listen
Elizabeth there's a deer right there
i'ma shoot that deer oh okay well let me
I'm gonna go back to bed
you know I I don't know what's happening
here but I feel funny feeling I should
go to sleep ease and that's what I'm
gonna do so can I put this gun away can
I sleep with the gun I didn't want I
didn't want to do that okay I'm gonna go
sleepy I'm go sleepy end of day easy to
continue wood 16 meat six water oh my
god I need so much more meat and I need
more water I survived another day okay
alright need more meat okay well that's
fine I'm sure there's gonna be plenty of
meat to have in the forest oh my god
wait is that a salt circle around my
bill is that a salt circle around my
building people put down salt circles to
try to keep demons at bay
Oh what is on that bridge is that a hole
in the bridge do I need to repair the
bridge can I upgrade my stats at some
point I mean I have more energy than I
had before I also don't see any deer
really but okay I'm gonna go hunting I'm
gonna try to dedicate this day to just
getting more food aid I suppose oh is
that a head why why are there just heads
everywhere
there we go okay oh those do increase my
maximum energy okay so that's good to
know
where's more food how do I get more
water to do I just have to draw it from
the well there's also a bridge up here
let me just go see if like I need to go
to it - no I need to repair it first
hello oh okay so I need to do that I
definitely need that I might want to aim
for that tomorrow and I definitely
shouldn't go to bed wasting any energy I
gotta use every scrap of my energy
possible possible let me try this is
this oh no that's that's all the water I
gots oh that's all my water okay
well let me go south first maybe there's
some more coast what is the what is wait
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what
is what the hell is that what is that
what the hell is that what the hell is
that what is that why is that why is it
there do I need to go and chop that up
with the axe would that even be a good
idea to eat that why is it there why do
i insult around my house what is going
on okay whatever I'm just gonna go
dingle-dangle my way down into the woods
I guess I gotta hurry up don't because
I'm gonna run out of imagine if I run
out of energy it's gonna end very badly
for me okay let me see let me see about
this thing first hey you get gone okay
nevermind then what happens if I run
myself dry of energy do I just instantly
pass out where I am because that
probably is not a good thing I'm gonna
I'm gonna take it safe and I'm just
gonna go to bed I love it I don't like
this some some very wrong about this and
today okay good not good any more water
which I can only assume means that I
need to go to another area
in order to do that I need wood wood the
wood is this sound getting louder to you
guys
let's so there doesn't seem to be any
new deer here so I think I'm might've
moved it
alright well I got that I do have a
slight problem of a complete lack of
food that is Oh more deer oh okay well
that's the thing
Oh God oh hey hey big guy hey big guy
how you what the hell what what happened
here what happened what the [ __ ] man
with the [ __ ] dude also what the hell
what the hell oh god there's a white
there's a weird white deer got ya what
is that is that a demon dear is that a
bad deer take a big food okay goodbye
big food big food big Mamba food and
grab this little increase there I'm
gonna get home I need more water and I
need more wood else I don't know why I'm
over a weird glowing void in the sky but
that's weird or in the ground going to
bed with my bucket on my head okay there
we go thank you
am I gonna die is this just like death
for me is that it I don't have water but
out of water but I survived another day
okay that's that's okay it's not good
but it's okay where do I get watered
I gotta get water where's water there's
got to be water up north right it's the
only place that I could possibly think
about water what about this is water No
okay so if it's gotta be water do I have
to bring water back to Oh what is that
what is
okay Oh water wait wait water well this
is a pain in the ass but at least I got
what at least I know where water is now
okay so I need to go get water I'm gonna
make today big water day today's all
about water baby gonna give uh uh uh
it's coming back for another pass what
the [ __ ] is that what the hell was that
what was that supposed to be okay I'm
gonna pretend like that was normal no
god damn it I want the freakin bucket I
can't imagine having to do this every
day okay I got water now I need to get
wood no we don't need to look at that
thing whatever that is we know we don't
fly as their planes overhead horrible
planes like the SCP planes heyy
I'm gonna go to bed with my axe okay
goodbye I'm good I'm doing better I'm
doing real good
I gotta go hunting tomorrow but that's
okay that big boy right there oh yeah
that before yeah wait there was a bucket
here I'll goddamn it I didn't I guess I
still need to run back anyway
sorry big boy sorry big boy there you go
big boy
oh yeah delicious Oh delectable
delectable
[Music]
what is what is that what is what
wouldn't know what the [ __ ] is bad oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh shoot it now
shoot it shoot it Judy Chu Chu Chu Chu
Chu Chu was that [ __ ] [ __ ] key
oh my god best day five [ __ ] is that
thing the devil is that the devil that's
haunting me is that the devil oh [ __ ]
well God dick
okay well that's uh that's it suck
that's such suck ass wood first I'm
gonna pair bridge or giddy Audi god damn
it I didn't know why there was gonna be
a demon coming out at me didn't know I
was gonna be popping out of the river is
it did it come out of the reflection or
something like that was that was that
liked it was that the crux of it like he
came out of the reflection because that
is kind of cool but at the same time
kind of horrifying
what's with the heads what is with the
hands why the heads why heads I take the
bucket I'm gonna go repair the top one
I'm gonna get some water soy before I
need it and then I'm gonna be good I'm
also gonna look for all the energy
doodads I want more energy baby give me
more energy baby oh god what's in these
woods oh god the woods are dense here
what the [ __ ] what is that
was this a golden axe what the [ __ ] is
it better oh my god it's so much better
what the [ __ ] I dropped my water I gotta
get back I'm gonna pass out and die out
here if I'm out here and I pass out I'm
gonna be real pissed it's probably only
better because it's able to cleave so
much now those went down in two hits
those definitely went down in two hits
whatever if I want wood is the wood get
er it is officially the wood get er or
maybe it's only maybe I can only use it
up there that's the case I just wasted
water
oh no it's upgraded it's upgraded it's
upgraded oh hell yeah
he's upgraded okay so I got a better axe
now all of a sudden that's good that's
good okay can I get a better water
bucket then is that another thing that I
can get let me go back up there cuz I
want to I want to see if I can get
enough wood out of this next batch then
I can just use that as like a launching
point to get more and more stuff right
so if I can just get in the dense
portion here start chopping willy-nilly
there we go I got two for one oh no it
still took the same amount of energy
yeah it still took to energy but now
trees only need do chops and that's good
so I'm gonna stop there for now I'm
gonna pick up the gun that's down here
on the pick up the gun I'm gonna shoot
me a deer hopefully one of the big boys
big boy in sight get out of here
there we go big boy got okay big boy got
keep big boy meat okay and then give big
boy out of here take a big boy out of
here and then we outie baby once we
outie reality for good so we get back in
bed we go Snoozeville
then we dunzo okay so tomorrow's goal
will be getting enough wood to open up
the next area I needed 30 for that I
think 30 was it 30 okay I've got 31 I
don't quite think it was a full 30 but
maybe I'm wrong do you need what do you
need what do you need
give me another cool thing oh he's only
25 okay that's good I got enough wood
for the next day so if I can get meat or
water I think I'll be able to survive
another day what is this place
oh hey oh it's the heads okay that's
just marble answer those
hands on the trees oh there's this
there's faces on the trees why their
faces on the trees why would there be
faces on the trees I don't want to risk
cutting one of those because they need
to save my energy but also that's
probably a problem if I just had to
venture a guess what is that
do you hear that oh is that a golden gun
it's a golden gun Oh baby oh baby oh
baby oh baby a triple okay so I need to
get I need to get a big boy but I don't
want just one of these to meet big boys
I want a whoppin for me big boy because
if I can if I'm gonna do without one
thing that I need and it's probably
gonna be water okay that's a lot of
bonus energy that's a lot of big dick
energy going on over there is that
another house wait hang on a second is
that that another house what the [ __ ]
what what is this another house over
here okay
then there's water here okay I guess I
got water now alright I have water at my
new house so that is that's good I think
okay but I still am low on food so we
need to go back to the other area I need
to get some big boy food for my big dick
energy go for it Oh sword I don't have a
sword
exactly I don't have a sword per se I've
got not a sword if that means anything
I'm just gonna shoot one of these things
alright that was Kumi worth I'm running
low on energy
Oh negative ten oh [ __ ] that's how it
does it okay well I needed this anyway
if I take a penalty for next time around
how about I probably would have been
fine [ __ ]
not ideal not ideal but it's okay not
ideal not ideal but it's okay but it's
okay so long as I live
that's what matters good struggling wait
so I there's no penalty for having
negative ten energy cuz that's cool I'm
okay with that I'm okay with that
all right honestly okay with it okay so
that's good to know also what is the
what does the gun do better than why is
it how is the gun any better than the
other one yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna go
clean out the entire forest kill
everything in the forest no [ __ ] not
gonna let you go
yeah I think it's the river I think it's
the river I'm pretty sure it's the River
Boesky there we go that's a big boy
that's a big boy
oh that's a big boy and an energy boost
oh that's the biggest boy what is that
Oh water plus mine flour it's hard okay
whatever I don't know what that is all
about but either way I got to get back I
get to get water or wood I probably
can't do without both I could do without
one I think but I don't think I could do
without both I'm gonna try to get water
okay sploosh in yoosh okay got that give
me the axe and I'm gonna go chop two
trees and then that's gonna be just
enough wood right one tote three fold
okay I'm out of energy but I'm perfectly
in line with the amount of materials
that I need so tomorrow I can make a
serious rush about becoming an
eco-terrorist and absolutely devastating
the entire forest around me literally
nothing will survive my onslaught
what am I do I'm gonna try to connect
I'm just gonna get wood woods what I
want woods what I need get a lot of wood
get a lot of wood I don't know how much
more wood I need for the next expansions
but I gotta imagine that it's gonna be
pretty good for me if I get them
depending on where I go maybe I don't
want to just connect the two because
it's that would just be a minor
convenience for the sake of water it's
not really the biggest deal in the world
but at the same time I mean maybe
there's a golden bucket that I'll get if
I get the next area how much wood does
this need Oh 15 that's it oh good good
great great excuse my voice cracking but
great I'm just a little prepubescent
today oh god bad
I went in the cemetery yeah [ __ ] that's
not good at all what is it rumbling what
is it rumbling I didn't want to come
down here I didn't want to come here at
all this is vana hey is that a ghost
that's a goose okay I'm gonna run away
from that okay hey hey hey hi no no no
where's my salt Circle don't even think
about it where's my salt Circle okay
it's right there it's right there I got
a salt Circle I can protect myself you
go away now that deer is on fire your
there is water or there holy [ __ ] I'm
gonna die but you knock down the tree
for me and I'll get some free wood now
Oh God he burst into meat or did you
just drop that me because you were
slightly on fires that what you did okay
whatever I'm gonna grab this fat a lot
of good it's gonna do me I'm gonna try
to grab this other thing you do not burn
me don't burn me I'm trying to do right
oh god you're gonna burn me aren't you
it's fine it's fine it's fine Terrell's
are good simply and good why is there no
goddamn like why is there no goddamn
blood you know what I'm saying
ice is so far away or maybe there's
another connection on the other side
over there that can do me some good like
that'll be another base probably maybe
I'm gonna chop a little more wood then
go to bed and then I'm gonna go down
there and try to fill in that hole
that'll probably a 25 or probably and
maybe that'll have a golden bucket and
then maybe that'll be good for me or
maybe it'll be just a big waste of my
time and I won't be able to do anything
and then I'm gonna die maybe that's
what's gonna happen
please let me chop two trees I don't
want to just get [ __ ] it over with one
yes okay got that all right [ __ ] I'm
outta here baby come on you know how did
you get out
oh you sack of [ __ ] get away from my
house get away from my house get away
from my house okay whatever I got what I
needed
kind of it's gonna be another 25 or so
if I get another 25 I get down there
it's good it's gonna be fine it's gonna
be fine good god that guy is a sack of
[ __ ] but it's gonna be fine
the chimes are really chiming today does
that mean there's a lot of demons out
yep that means a lot of deep [ __ ] you oh
my god who's who on whose authority are
you a piece of [ __ ] don't kill me oh god
oh god oh god please please not like
this anything about this now okay not
like this good god good god please help
help huh oh my die
Zoe die I'm gonna die so the chimes are
pretty good at oh but here the chimes
are a pretty good indicator that shits
about to go down and the devil is indeed
haunting me and I am about to get boner
owned over real hard
oh it's getting real fun dry out there
no no how about you know
okay all right oh [ __ ] I almost got
rocks thumbs got rocked by that deer
okay I think it's fine it's not fine
it's not fine it's not fine it's not
fine it's not fine it's not fine it's
not fine is it fine
I can't tell that's fine probably not
fine I just want to go repair this
goddamn bridge please mother mae-eye
mother mae-eye mother may i mother may i
okay yes yes yes I may yes mother may
may yes it's a new house oh no no do not
no not today not today
no not tomorrow not ever please don't do
this to me
I got a Jew come duke nukem new house
okay there's some water back there
that's good to know I hate this devil
it's just water in there come on come on
as clearly water in there but I gotta go
get the water over to the left don't I
well that's okay cuz that is indeed a
little closer so let me go get the water
it'll be good there's my new home base
with water right next door it's one
little water there we go just a little
water please there's a little water
okay I got my water in those lying level
of water piece of garbage brick that
double Frick that devil writing this
Frick hole somehow I need to get that
sword in it just the idea of getting
enough water over there that's gonna
work also I think wait no oh I get it
the water was for the flowers to get
more hearts so that I could be tougher
getting more wood and that's good
oh there's oh there's a flower there I
think that is what is gonna get me life
okay
my understanding is that I just need to
water that and then I'll get more hearts
there another bridge up north then is
there another bridge up here no there's
not there's not he's just a bunch of
bull oh here he comes he's gonna get
angrier everyday yeah okay whatever sack
of [ __ ] the answer is No
oh thanks with a free wood [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh god damn it of course I can't
go north immediately after I get out of
the [ __ ] bridge oh yeah yeah oh yeah
gimme give me some free wood [ __ ] give
me some free wood aah
high five that's I screamed so you
thought it'd be real yeah that's right
that's right you can't
you cannot oh [ __ ] you cannot Oh you
think you think I've got I've got I've
got you played for a fool for a fool you
fool oh you fool
oh you fool oh oh [ __ ] okay yeah okay I
don't like this nearly as much you're
getting a little a little to adaptive
here yeah wrong wrong wrong
all wrong all day now how does it feel
to be so wrong get out of here that [ __ ]
I don't think there's another circle
over farther left so I'm just gonna
count my blessings that I got this year
I'm killing up a storm but that's
alright okay so I've got 40 left I can
get more stuff I don't know how to pull
the sword out of the stone I'm guessing
it must be something to do with all the
heart flowers right so I gotta I got to
do all the heart flower things then is
that what I got to do cuz that's it's
gonna be a lot of running I'm not good
with cardio it's not my favorite thing
oh here he [ __ ] comes okay alright
okay oh that was too close that was
right on my nip knobs oh boy oh and
Ellie there whoa Nellie Nellie oh thank
you for the free wood whoa Nellie I
gotta be close there it is oh but no
he's gonna okay I need to get water to
these things that's what I gotta do
my only objective now is to get more
water again really [ __ ] hug brilli
wait are you here or not what the [ __ ]
is the deal oh god oh god oh god no oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god him
I'm too low I'm too old I'm too low for
the thing oh yeah yeah okay bridge over
water water over the bridge no no no no
not like this oh god oh god oh god I'm
so scared
please don't kill me not now I'm so far
in my game I'm so far in my game thank
you for the tree kill you sack of [ __ ]
don't kill me thank you for the trees
that you're bringing to their knees yeah
yeah
how in the [ __ ] am I gonna get more
water how in the [ __ ] am I gonna do this
I should just sleep cuz [ __ ] I only have
one heart I can't risk it got plenty of
other [ __ ] I don't want to risk it
therefore I won't risk it why even
bother chopping wood anymore he does a
better job of it than me than I ever
could okay I'm just gonna go to bed
because [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm out I'm just
like next step is just water that's all
I gotta do kill this [ __ ] kill this
[ __ ] [ __ ] douche bag always coming
after me skinning me by the hairs of my
balls and I don't want anything about it
I don't want anything about it I don't
anything about it nothing or nothing for
nobody about it nothing for nobody here
it goes whoa these are meat trees wait a
minute what the [ __ ] is that about
meat trees holy [ __ ] I don't want to
know what the story is buying the meat
trees but that's horrifying that's why
they had faces on that's why it seemed
bad all right I got you I think I think
I'm pretty well got you handled oh [ __ ]
no I don't [ __ ] of course I get cocky
and the second I get cocky is the second
I get cocked [ __ ] of course oh my god
of course of course of course
of course a horse of course a horse a
horse of course I'm gonna die there's
there's a there's a flower over here oh
my god if I get caught up in those oh
that no no no listen no no no no no you
do not get to do that to me not two of
you [ __ ] [ __ ] coming at me all
flying style like a bunch of pieces of
[ __ ] can you want to come after me
that's fine that's fine but the ghosts
that's where I draw the [ __ ] line
okay all right and the line is right
here I drew it [ __ ] off with you know
that if that would have hit me I would
have been infinitely pissed I'm gonna go
for it again I get this no you don't get
to do that to me no you don't get to do
that no you don't
oh no you don't but he's coming back
farting happy oh he's coming back hot
and heavy okay I got a heart yay
do I just gotta do that to all of them I
just need to is that all I really need
because that's not hard okay I don't
know how many there are a total but okay
that wasn't that bad
okay there's oh really another ghost
yeah you think you're gonna get me huh
[ __ ] you I still don't know why there's
no golden bucket should I feel like
there should be like this only fair okay
- all right
as a bunch I'm gonna do this all day oh
I can do this all day baby
I can do this all it no I can't no scary
but I've got one more heart so you can
[ __ ] right off I'm just gonna get a
bunch of water bunch of water big old
buckets full of water
I'm like dishing out water for days ohh
water all over you water everywhere
maybe that's like a limit of how much
water you can actually hold
yeah whatever it doesn't matter I'm I
have water gushing everywhere I was
gonna be losing out everywhere no ghosts
II don't even think about a ghostie you
even think about it and you do big big
big demon boy don't even think about it
that must be it right that must be the
end game if I get all of the hearts I
can get this sward and then I can kick
this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
ass from here I'm not sure of this I'm
not sure of this water is shared between
all the wells by some weird magical
thing I'd like to think so but maybe not
go see you if you would have heard me
there I would have been I mean I would
have just been emotionally devastated
okay no oh there's no limit all right
well that's nice actually I've got
enough water there let me go take this
to the north back up to like where I
know there's another flower I don't
think there's another flower here I
think that's the only one here so it
must be oh [ __ ]
well we got company tango incoming Oh
tango outgoing [ __ ] get out of here get
out of what are you doing hanging around
get out of here cut it oh just gonna
take this up to the northern area
there's a flower right north of my ah ah
ting tang walla walla bing bang yeah now
I'm good I like this I like this game
it's an interesting challenge the
gameplay is tight I get it simple
mechanics like it all makes sense when
you really think about it it's a good
game sploosh okay that was one okay let
me see if I can grab more water from my
well that'd be cool
yeah okay it is shared across all that
is delightful okay
sploosh II douche now I got four hearts
baby four hearts yeah that guy's gonna
have a tough time getting to me now okay
so the other one I don't know if there's
one more or two more
I'm gonna guess one more man remember
when I thought that it was the
reflection of the the river that pulled
him out of the other dimension man now
stupid to me boy I sure was a dumb right
guys right where was you there was you
it's up there okay that must be the last
one that must be the last one right
right for sho fo sho and then there's a
well right down here grab the water
finish it off I'm good to go
I'm good go let's go let's go oh I'm so
full of hard Oh
okay so then the sword must be available
now right
that's the dealio is that the dealio do
I need a full do I need like do I need
like a night's rest to make this happen
or can I just go for it I think that's
that must be it right oh oh he's coming
back you want to play we'll play buddy
okay oh I'll play with you all the way
back to the sword which I'm gonna use to
kick your ass oh I'm gonna kick your
fast here Tuesday mister okay please
wait until he shoots off another load
before I get on that bridge okay all
right yeah nor they innate sexuality of
what I just said about you you are done
zone me you were done zone mister excuse
my screams of Terror they're just what I
am going to I'm imitating you in the
future when I kick your ass I don't care
if I don't have enough energy to do this
I'm still I'm gonna I'm gonna kick your
ass I'm gonna take a nap and imma kick
your ass some more yeah
you devil bastard
oh you think oh you killing trees
thinking that that's gonna do anything
to me no you ain't gonna never know oh
[ __ ] okay well one you get one alright
you get one you get one you get one you
were a little close to me it was a
little unfair whatever what are its
gotta be unfair if you gonna have any
chance standing up against me that's
right yeah you goin kid nothing you get
a whole lot of nothing you get dick
diddly squat poop and a bag of Doritos
that's half crunched and like had a leak
in it so it had it got stale that's what
you get fame out trade this bucket for a
sword Okabe swords can get for this
bucket I mean how many swords do you
think I can get for this bucket here
okay alright alright hey I've got a
sword huh Wow Xiao Lu Shou come on baby
come on baby you want some of this
oh whoops ow so is that so is this is
this a speed hacks is for speedrun
tactics I can go even faster now well
you gonna get with share baby I'll get
some more sure honey
want some more Savion we're sure oh you
want some of this one's okay oh yeah you
want some oh you don't
oh you think you do oh but you do not
what oh okay [ __ ] [ __ ] get stitches
[ __ ] ouch oh [ __ ] I got it didn't think
I got that he wants for this of a
disability
nope you do not owe you
oh you think you do but you do not oh
and push I know what you up to
I know what you up to I've been seeing
you enough of you all day every day
100% you've done so you done so you
think you not dunzo
oh you burnt to a crisp you so Danzo
take you off the stove pull you at the
oven you Danzo you'd onion rings you go
you need a good dipping sauce to go you
sold onion rings seafood sauce on that
cuz you don Mian you dhania oh yeah
you'd onion
oh you sewed on [ __ ] yeah oh yes
hell yeah oh [ __ ] why is it so ding dong
e God are you happy
did I beat the devil are you happy
you're back mad you happier man oh it's
a bed
okaywell still got my sword what do I
finally get to sleep
yay I think I did it
and now I drift off into eternal bliss
of Perpetual silence and slumber meaning
I'm dead hey that was awesome honestly I
had so much fun with that that was
honestly legitimately fun the time I
played that for an hour and 15 minutes
it was cut down way longer for you but I
played that for an hour 50 minutes flew
by for me so fun the whole time
very stressful especially not knowing
what was going on very weird very scary
but cool I really like that that was not
bad at all
loved it so thank you everybody so much
for making watching this thank you for
the developer for making this game I
heard this was actually made in seven
days for a game Jim this was really
really cool very simplistic gameplay
very simplistic graphics but well done
it kept me engaged it kept like the
carrot on a stick going a little bit
farther each time there was a reason to
upgrade it was just difficult enough I
liked it a lot I liked it a lot so thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you want to play this for yourself and
try to see if there's any other secrets
that I didn't find because I think there
might have been with all those weird
heads and stuff but no bird you can find
this game in the description below thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you want to help support the channel
click that joined button it helps me
make great projects like Wilfred
mother-loving wharfs - who killed
markiplier and date with markiplier and
other big stuff that's coming real soon
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you
by
[Music]